20 ans de carrière au sein des Guignols
de l'Info 19 émissions de télévision
comment plus 30 ans après ils m'ont mis
20 ans
88 2018 d'accord 30 ans 4 doublures de
voies au cinéma
oui oui tu es sûr ça va oui oui
trois albums
oui oui tu sais quoi tu as intérêt dire
oui tout le temps parce que ça va me
gêner
j'essaie de me souvenir parce que j'en
ai fait trop on est très sûr de ce que
l'on fait évidemment Agatha est
formidable la gaz de roulant allez deux
livres les mémoires d'un Guignol et fous
de château on va en parler évidemment
bien sûr alors toi tu es un des plus
grands humoristes français imitateur et
tout voilà comment ça se travaille la
voix là ça se travaille pas ça se
problème c'est que moi je suis pas un
grand travailleur je suis toujours
occupé mais je suis pas un travailleur
il faut absolument que je et souvent les
voix s'imposent avec du temps
quelquefois elle part d'un coup donc on
peut pas dire que ça se travaille un
jour guignol me disait tiens ce soir on
fait bah on se dit
et tout de suite là-bas sortait il y a
des voix qui sortent tout de suite et
d'autres que je mets des mois à posséder
si je veux dire oui mais à l'époque moi
je sais à l'école je crois que déjà tu
imitait et tu faisais rire toute ta
classe
bien sûr parce que sans le savoir
s'imiter bien sûr j'imitais la nounou
elle m'a appelé
c'est déjà fait on ne coupe pas vas-y
est-ce qu'il y a une voix qu'on vous
demande tout le temps de faire quand on
vous croise
oui oui quand même il y a la vedette
c'est Chirac et vous détestez faire
pourquoi
de si ça a servi quand même et je veux
dire Chirac on me demande ce Chirac
maintenant que PPDA alors que PPDA quand
il était plus sur TF1 on lui parlait en
tant que marionnette c'est-à-dire comme
s'il avait été en vrai alors qu'il était
au Guignol et il te trouvait formidable
à Patrick tu le sais à force oui mais au
début c'était quand même un peu mal vu
quoi
c'est vrai que quand on a du mal à tu
vois il y a certains imitateurs qui
militent mais moi je me reconnais pas on
se reconnaît pas et moi c'est ce que me
disait
[Rires]
le mieux je trouve et dis-moi alors par
exemple
[Rires]
alors justement Jacques Chirac tu as dû
le rencontrer forcément non
à l'époque Céline Renaud qui m'avait
foutu dans ce traquenard d'aller à son
anniversaire à la mairie de Paris j'ai
été fiché chiracien du jour au lendemain
ça m'a coûté un million d'impôts
[Applaudissements]
mais Chirac la met toujours en scène
parce sur scène moi je fais revivre ces
grands moments puisque c'est de
50 ans de le titre du spectacle donc on
passe le béton par Bernadette qui est le
dialogue qui avait dialogue de sourds
entre elle et son mari mais bon
Bernadette c'est pas oui je l'imitais
parce qu'il fallait limiter non mais
c'était drôle tu disais par exemple à
propos de Jacques Chirac
et là maman
ça j'adore et ça ça me faisait mourir de
rire alors il y a d'autres voix qui sont
peut-être il y a Gainsbourg birkis Nina
Simone Philippe Bouvard
s'il te plaît
personne ne reconnaît enfin il se
reconnaissait pas après ça il me courait
après pour que je garde son théâtre de
Bobino
[Applaudissements]
et Gainsbourg tu peux nous faire jukebox
alors même dans l'intimité je peux vous
dire honnêtement quand on dit tous les
deux je lui dis fais-moi machin fais-moi
machin c'est tellement drôle
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime moi non plus c'était jouer le
rôle de l'aspirateur je vais et je viens
en 220 enfin c'était
quelle était la voix la plus difficile à
faire en fait
celle que j'ai pas réussi à faire mais
il y a pour ça quand il y a un imitateur
qui fait une voix que je fais pas je
m'incline je dis bravo parce que je veux
pas être d'ailleurs on était plusieurs
au Guignols tout le monde le mettait
tout sur le dos mais on avait quand même
des il y avait des participants avec moi
il y avait il y a eu comme tout qui est
arrivé aussi
et qui a laissé voir à lui qui était à
l'époque très drôle et puis il y a eu
ben Marc-Antoine Lebret qui est moi j'ai
repéré que j'ai essayé de lancer parce
que je trouvais qu'il avait un enfant
puis bon oui c'est difficile parce que
il y en a plusieurs bons hein
je te dis le bref c'était mon préféré à
l'époque je sais pas je suis pas trop
depuis quelques temps mais parce que
j'ai pas le temps de regarder d'écouter
ses émissions mais je pense que c'est
quand même un des meilleurs mais il y en
a d'autres qui sont moins connus voilà
qui était une jeune génération
ouais la chanson on l'a lancé à Graines
de star avec leur envoyer et il a fait
un parcours incroyable il a des voix
musicale extraordinaires tu l'avais
animé gangster toi aussi oui c'est bon
avec avec Boyer ouais mais alors
justement
on parle souvent de toi et tu es
toujours associé un peu au château alors
voilà alors là c'est pour ça qu'un jour
j'arrive chez un de tes collègues là
Jordan Deluxe et il me dit avec tous les
châteaux dont on parlait vous êtes
milliardaire j'ai reprises j'ai oublié
de parler de on en parlera parce que je
crois que on a parlé d'argent tout à
l'heure
c'est ça parce que le télépectateur
sache qu'on va en parler évidemment mais
pas encore moi ce que j'aimerais savoir
puisque tu as une très belle carrière et
avoir des châteaux c'est pas avoir de
l'argent ça va bien
tu as beaucoup collaboré à la télévision
alors tu as travaillé avec Drucker avec
Daniel Gilbert aussi tu as fait oui bien
sûr j'étais tous les jours son émission
et même aux Antilles j'étais là-bas
je crois que ça fait le coq
je reviendrai mais il faut les aimer non
pour les imiter comme ça pas forcément
parce que moi j'ai mis le Pen je n'ai
pas envie
ah oui d'accord oui oui
mais malgré tout il faut non il faut pas
forcément aimer les gens mais il faut
respecter ben alors voilà personnalité
ils existent ils sont là ça donne quoi
Le Pen déjà
je suis un peu malade
alors
il y a quand même des gens des
personnalités qui ont un peu souffert
des caricatures que vous pouviez faire
Johnny Hallyday par exemple qui dit
[Rires]
il a compris que c'était pas si mauvais
la boîte oui mais quand même ça permet
de d'ouvrir la boîte où je travaillais
pour la boîte de nuit
beaucoup
le langage Guignol et papa c'est un
imbécile enfin bon après ça papa s'est
vu applaudit grâce à ça
qui est passé grâce à ça donc tu es pas
la brutalement un cerveau
pour deux alors attends exagéré
ça un cerveau pour deux tu sais que je
travaille à l'époque donc sur vidéo gag
avec Alexandre Debanne et vous nous
aviez fait dans les Guignols tu sais
quoi ils sont même pas casser la tête à
nous faire les marionnettes ça coûte
cher un visage à fabriquer un vous avez
juste mis deux pieds à l'envers
il a très mal pris de me souviens et il
voulait attaquer laisse tomber et tu
sais qu'Alexandre de bonne a beaucoup
d'humour mais c'est vrai qu'il est sur
le coup on l'a mal pris moi ça m'a fait
rire mais c'est vrai que deux pieds
disent même pas cassé la tête à faire
nos têtes il y avait une forme de
méchanceté mais qui faisait rire donc
c'était méchant pour ceux qui étaient
visés parce qu'il prenaient ça au
premier degrés mais sinon ça leur
faisait une cote j'ai plutôt positif que
négatif Chirac il était mécontent au
départ de manger des pommes c'est ça
qu'il a fait élire pratiquement
sympathique
non mais c'est vrai que Chirac on a
profit tout le monde dit ah oui c'est
vous qui l'avez fait lire alors quand
évidemment les auteurs de l'époque ont
appris ça ils ont démissionné tellement
ils étaient dégoûtés parce qu'il faisait
tout pour ça ça mais même c'est tout
pour contre Sarkozy Sarkozy ça va pas
empêcher de passer ah tu sais bien
Sarkozy aussi c'est vrai
j'ai un bracelet vous le voyez pas
je suis là en tant que chariot de Carla
pas en tant que politique
je retourne d'ailleurs bientôt voir en
prison la demande
le Valois voilà je voudrais je voudrais
quand même pour conclure un peu ces
imitations Johnny parce que Johnny c'est
une merveille c'est toi qui a vraiment
un carnet de Johnny je m'étais fous de
rage et après
[Musique]
une émission où je suis un spectacle je
sais plus et il est venu me voir il m'a
dit Chirac tu changes rien ne m'a pas
dit toi tu changes tout
ça voulait dire mais Johnny il a accepté
le traitement quand il s'est aperçu de
la cote que si on va lui avait donné
parce qu'il était quand même entre
guillemets dans le corps de la vague
comme toi
et après ça ça lui a fait une conne
terrible donc c'est vraiment pour
l'école pour sa fille tout ça c'était
pas drôle c'était très dur c'était très
dur à vivre ça c'était le premier à
l'admettre mais je veux dire c'était pas
encore moi le grand le grand chef
là-dedans mais
positivement c'était quand même quelque
chose de gagner pour lui c'est vrai
pardon mais il y avait il y avait
Philipp aussi il y avait Johnny Hallyday
il y avait silver store Stallone et
Philippe Campello
c'est pas gentil de rappeler ça tu as
quelque chose les Guignols valaient
mieux y être que Payet ça c'est vrai et
par contre j'arrivais à l'entraînement
où il y avait tous mes collègues qui se
foutaient de ma gueule qu'est-ce
que tu as morflé hier les coups d'épée
dans le dos la fourchette dans le
premier
c'est toi qui faisait Candeloro je sais
plus à l'époque parce que
je crois qu'au début c'était
Erza qui t'y mettait exactement
rendre à césar aussi était dans l'équipe
et illimité Philippe
c'est pas très compliqué
à seulement les biscotos quoi
mais c'est vrai que certains l'ont plus
évidemment en tant que téléspectateurs
ont adorait mais en tant que journaliste
on a aussi des gens qui vraiment étaient
en souffrance là tu passes
plus
ce soir je fais pas le match je joue pas
le match
moi voisin à l'époque au Pilat il était
vraiment pas content du tout
avec le coq tu peux lui dire qu'il
arrête un peu c'était pas pareil
justement ils avaient aucun moyen de le
faire arrêter
de leur quarteron d'auteur mais déjà
j'étais archi bourré de travail j'avais
pas en plus mais même mettre 20 ans en
guignol donc je ne suis jamais été avec
eux bon genre porter la responsabilité
mais là c'est pas le cas c'était on ne
changeait pas une virgule de ce qu'ils
écrivent aller tu as déjà refusé des
textes voilà c'est ce que j'adore
ils ont fait un texte contre moi maman
oui parce que j'étais j'avais fait une
émission chez Stéphane Bern célébrité et
donc donc c'est le rêve un peu plus haut
guignol les auteurs de l'époque
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait l'ex imitateur
vedette était reçu voilà ce qui m'avait
tapé dessus c'est moi qui ai dit le
texte tu vois donc c'était quand même la
preuve que j'acceptais tous les textes
même contre moi vous pourriez plus
jamais enfin c'était quand même à
l'époque hyper libre quand même
mais à l'époque c'était c'était tendance
c'était c'était nouveau
c'était en direct absolu enfin c'était
un truc insensé qui ne pourrait plus se
refaire aujourd'hui ceux qui disent je
vais reprendre des Guignols c'est bidon
là